thank you
ladies and gentlemen good afternoon
and welcome to this afternoon's press
conference following today's European
Council
now we have journalists joining us
remotely but today will actually only be
taking questions from journalists
present in the room
uh without further Ado I'd like to give
the floor to the president of the
European Council Mr Sharma show
mercy good morning everyone
is organizations
communication
[Music]
[Music]
uh today we had the European council
meeting and we had the occasion again to
listen to the president of Ukraine that
new zelinski had the occasion to address
uh all of us and to share with us the
priorities of Ukraine this is the
occasion for for us to reiterate our
full support for Ukraine this is an
aggression this is a next an
unacceptable war and we are determined
to mobilize all possible tools and means
in order to support Ukraine which
financial means with Military Support
with humanitarian support and of course
with political support at the same time
you know that we took decisions in order
to strengthen the sanctions against
Russia because we think that we need to
put pressure against Kremlin but also
the occasion today and yesterday to
mention importance to reach out to third
countries you know to count the Russian
narrative we know that this war decided
by Russia has huge consequences not only
for the European continent but also for
the world the food security crisis and
the energy crisis and you know that you
are determined to support our partners
across the world when it comes to the
food security crisis but we had also the
occasion today this is the third point I
would like to mention to address the
energy crisis the energy situation and
the economic and social consequences of
that crisis locations
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you president Michelle I now
passed the floor to president bondoline
very much first of all I would like to
thank our host dear prime minister the
better for the outstanding reception and
the warmth with which we have been
welcomed here in this fantastic
environment these were two very
impressive days and we will keep them in
best memory so many many things for that
to the presidency we had of course
yesterday the European political
Community for the very first time
I think the composition was telling
there were 44 countries United
discussing the challenges of today and
it showed how much Russia is isolated by
now
but it also showed how strong the
support for Ukraine is the prime
minister was present president zielinski
joined us via video conference and it
was an important message and signal to
show that the European countries are
determined to defend the rule of law the
international rights the charter that we
all hold so dear of course we had today
also then the discussion on Ukraine and
how we can support Ukraine as long as it
takes
um I'm very encouraged that we managed
yesterday to close the latest rounds of
hard biting sanctions against Russia in
record time
once again we've moved fast and we have
moved with Force
we've made progress on the oil price cap
with our enhanced export ban we continue
to undermine Putin's ability to wage war
in Ukraine and with our widened import
ban we deprive him further of important
revenues
this shows Putin that the European Union
is determined to continue making him pay
for his war of aggression
and in parallel we continue to stand
firmly with Ukraine
team Europe that is the EU and the
member states
is Ukraine's most important supporter
alongside the United States
we are providing by now since the
beginning of the war 19 billion euros
for Ukraine this is without counting
military assistance
and this includes that a further 2
billion euros in macro financial
assistance will be released in the
coming days
of course we will not only have to look
at the immediate relief with financial
support but also at the midterm the
reconstruction
supporting Ukraine in this endeavor is
the purpose of a joint conference
that the commission and 37 presidency
will hold at the end of this month in
Berlin it was very good to hear the
other leaders on this very important
issue on reconstruction of Ukraine
what is already clear is that we will
have to identify new financing sources
because this is a massive amount that
will be needed
and we will have to establish a very
structured approach to ensure
predictability for the financing
transparency on the how it's going to be
done and of course
today seven months into the war that
Russia has Unleashed against Ukraine we
are much better prepared for the winter
than it was the case before
just to give you a figure at the
beginning of the worm
the overall imported gas
41 was Russian gas
today we are down to 7.5 percent and
that shows how much we have progressed
in diversifying away from Russia getting
rid of our dependency from Russian
fossil fuels and turning towards more
reliable supplier
our storages are filled by 90 by now
this is compared to last year same time
15 more so we are in a very good State
what that is concerned
and therefore the discussion focused on
the question of the high gas prices
overall and the high electricity prices
as you know I have sent a letter to
detail out a road map how to approach
these topics
so the question of negotiating a
corridor for decent prices with our
reliable suppliers or for example
looking at how to limit prices in the
mark against Market overall and to look
at how to limit the influence of gas in
the price formation of electricity all
these topics have been discussed with
the view that within the roadmap more
detailed proposals will come from the
commission for the next weeks ahead of
us
one thing is very clear there's a broad
support that next spring at the end of
the winter when our storages will be
depleted it is of Paramount importance
that we have a joint purchase
purchasement procurement of gas so that
we avoid to outbit each other but that
we have a collective bargaining power
and that we put that in place
all these views on the gas market the
electricity prices are so important
because we have to keep our single
Market together
and we have to avoid fragmentation
I emphasize once again how crucial that
is and this is an opinion that was
widely shared time and again
the single Market has proven to be our
single best asset in times of crisis
therefore we need to preserve it it's of
Paramount importance that we have a
Level Playing Field and that we avoid
fragmentation and distortion
on the contrary we have to make possible
that there are investments we have to
double down on investments in homegrown
Renewables not only for the climate but
also because the transition to the clean
energy is the best way to again
Independence and to have security of
energy Supply
this is why we will be looking at
additional funding to be channeled
through repower issue we need all
countries to have the necessary
resources to invest in clean energy
finally last but not least a word on the
protection of critical infrastructure
what happened with North stream 1 and
North stream 2 is clearly the type of
threats
we will have to get used to but more
importantly be prepared for
and as you know the commission presented
a five-point plan
on preparedness on stress testing on
response on International coordination
and on information Exchange
our work Starts Now
it is very good that we have already
legislation in place during the French
presidency it was developed so we are
anticipating now the entry into force of
these new EU roles rules on the
resilience of critical entities and
cyber security and thus strengthening
our critical infrastructure of course we
will also be reaching out to
International Partners first and
foremost NATO the resilience of critical
infrastructure is bound to become a
crucial aspect of our EU NATO
cooperation thank you very much
thank you madam president and now the
floor to prime minister fella thank you
ladies and gentlemen and I'm glad that
we followed up on yesterday's successful
meetings first meeting of
EPC and we would discuss energy and
Russian war in Ukraine and its influence
on the European Union in detail
I welcome the consensus of a training
mission of Ukraine troops in the EU it's
an important step which will help you
cry into sustain War I am glad that the
ambassadors of the EU approved another
sanction package the most important
element is the cup of Russian oil which
is transported in tankas
Europe have become too dependent on
Russian energy and Russia uses energy
sources resources as a weapon we must
stop this dependence to be Sovereign I
am glad that we openly discussed
proposal of the president of the
European commission to decouple the
price of gas from the price of
electricity we also talked about release
of additional
ETS allowances from the market stability
Reserve in order to reduce their price
and of course other possible measures
Czech president civil work hard together
with commission on the further steps in
discus topics it special solution of
high energy prices it's very important
we will organize as many meetings of the
Council of ministers as necessary
species
over
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
Brussels
thank you prime minister
now I suggest we first take a few
questions from the Czech media I suggest
Lucas mate from Czech TV
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
thanks very much Martinez status New
York Times
um a question about something different
my colleagues in New York last night
reported President Biden's latest
comments regarding
um Putin's nuclear threats he warned of
the possibility of a nuclear Armageddon
that's a direct quote he also said that
Putin isn't joking when he makes these
threats
I wonder if your U.S counterparts or
member State intelligence Services have
shared specific recent intelligence that
points Beyond Mr Putin's public
statements that points to increased risk
of a nuclear attack or use of nuclear
weapons tactical or otherwise
do you share the assessment that he's
not joking and we are risking a nuclear
Armageddon or do you consider that
language hyperbolic thank you
thank you Martina
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
well indeed we're taking the threats of
President Putin serious as we take any
of his quotes serious and at the same
time as with any of his quotes we're not
being blackmailed by what he says we
have a very clear stance on how we want
to proceed
thank you and one last question John
Anger from Bloomberg
thank you John angel from Bloomberg
um to president Michelle and Wonderland
um coming into this meeting there didn't
really seem to be a clear view on what
exactly member states wanted when it
came to a gas price cap do you now have
Clarity on what it is exactly they are
converging on which gas price caps are
still on the table and which other
things like demand reduction might have
to be implemented and president
Wonderland you mentioned your letter and
the call for new funds was that
discussed today and would you like to
see more borrowing to fund some of the
energy measures that the commission
plans on taking thank you
the The Experience shows that uh in the
decision-making process on the EU side
this is very useful to have such a
meeting an informal meeting without the
political pressure of written
conclusions but with the occasion to
listen to each other and to try to
understand better what are the different
opinions what are different
sensitivities and I would like to share
with you our experience today we listen
to the different opinions priorities
expressed and we felt that the result a
real feeling of a need for a pragmatic
approach it means that there is a world
map proposed by the the commission it
was extremely helpful to have to have a
framework I repeat that we are located
to this first three points in fact the
demand how we can reduce the
transcription and we can see only in a
few weeks that we are able to mobilize
our people to mobilize our businesses
because we have demonstrated in a few
weeks or months that we are able to be
responsible to show responsibilities in
that field point one point to the supply
I would like to come back to the
traction for instance ideation a few
weeks ago to travel to Algeria Qatar the
Emirates Saudi Arabia it means that we
need to engage with certain countries
countries that can be reliable Partners
in the in the future for our energy
resource and I put that point in Lynch
with the the common purchase platform
which is an idea that we've already
discussed a few months ago and and we
feel that they should really support I'm
more concrete I repeat again for
instance to to fill the stocks in the
future it could be a powerful tool in a
little in fact for our supply but also
for the third element the price the
price you know then there are some some
words more sensitive from an ideological
point of view but today it was extremely
extremely valuable execution to the
stand that there is a common will for a
German European approach all of us
should understand that it's not possible
to have 27 National initiatives and that
was that approach we would overcome the
challenges and the difficulties we
understand that we need based on EU
coordination and you understood that
there is a very strong role play Not
only by the commission but also by
rotating presidency and again I commend
the leadership of the Czech presidency
because we have seen the recent weeks
and months an absolute determination to
address those challenges and to make
sure that this is possible to take
decisions together the natural
principles will be extremely important
but not only the Ethiopian Council also
the Council of ministers it has been set
in I repeat there is an important role
that needs to be played and also at the
level of the Council of the EU
so
we have very clear objectives and these
objectives have been laid down in the
roadmap letter
this we have discussed
first of all it is to coordinate the
procurement
because it needs a common trust and
transparency about the offers of gas
that we will then purchase together
in order to make sure that we do not
outbit our ourselves on the global
market
the second objective is to tame the gas
prices
this is done in several ways you can
have a negotiated Corridor with reliable
suppliers
this work has already started with
Norwegian companies
you can in a second approach and this is
important look at how you limit the gas
price
so that we take out the Peaks and the
speculation out of the gas price at the
ttf level
a very important point that we discussed
and then you can have a third look at
the gas prices how you partially
decouple the influence of the gas price
in the formation of the electricity
price
this might be the first step for a
far-reaching market reform
that we are envisaging but only towards
the beginning of next year because this
is a very complex
complex endeavor
this is uh the gold in the gas price
Market
looking at the financing
first of all it's important that now
re-power gets the final agreement of
council and European Parliament
repower EU has all what is necessary in
governance
to make it possible to invest
in critical infrastructure like
pipelines interconnectors and Renewables
but also to invest in businesses and
households insulating houses or heat
pumps and other technologies that are
necessary
and for that we will be looking in
additional funding
on a European level so that all member
states have the same opportunity to
invest in the transition that I was just
describing
ladies and gentlemen that brings this
Prince conference to a close I'd like to
add my words of thanks to the press to
the Czech presidency for hosting us and
look forward to seeing you all in two
weeks time thank you
watch out okay